spüren sie das eigentlich auch oder ein
aufatmen geht durchs ganze land es ist
so erst anfang märz aber das schlimmste
liegt bereits hinter uns wenn ich das
schlimmste sage meine ich natürlich
karneval ja beziehungsweise den
politischen aschermittwoch
gerade in so einem wahljahr wissen sie
lässt ja keine partei die gelegenheit
aus sich unter das alkoholisierte wahl
volk zu mischen
nach heute leute seien es ist ja es ist
gut gemeint aber in der konsequenz führt
genau das dann leider ja oft zu einer
neuen dimension der fremdscham es ist
kein bier auf hawaii um warum warum
materie
prof
hollywood mindestlohn ii steigern
o
und das schlimme ist man kann es nicht
ungeschehen machen es ist im gehirn
drinnen sorry meine damen und herren ja
angela merkel die hat es im gegensatz
dazu gut denn frau merkel hat neuerdings
ein karnevals atteste habe jetzt muss ak
für sie in die bütt trotzdem haben die
gnadenlosen bekloppten sie auch dieses
jahr heimgesucht in ihrem berliner
kanzler plattenbau und da hat man doch
direkt wieder gemerkt dass unsere
kanzlerin mit dem ganzen thema karneval
ja irgendwie fremdelt und ich danke der
sellerie garde der knoblauchsländer
karnevalsgesellschaft buchnesia 1954
[Applaus]
[Musik]
da war kein gag bei den damen und herren
aber lieber einmal zuviel tuschen genau
100 jahre politischer aschermittwoch
feiern die in diesem jahr das fakt seit
1919 treffen sich also menschen zum
gemeinsamen bierzelt kurzen plus
pöbeleien auf der bühne
das ist ja das unterhaltungsprogramm da
würde die politische konkurrenz mal so
richtig auf links gedreht
söder zum beispiel anders gesehen söder
war dieses jahr wieder super jetzt
neuerdings voll männlich mit
dreitagebart und dann sahen zwei
journalisten aber es sieht aber gar
nicht mal so schlecht aus ja ja ich weiß
jetzt wie habe ich und so darf sie
würden sich das doch nie trauen sagen
mal eins ja so lässig wie der sind wir
schon lange
bloß weg bei uns mehr liebe freunde das
ist der unterschied
kennst du kennst ja dass liebe kinder
war bayerisch für männer ist viel länger
als der vom habe ja nie wo und karneval
müssen sich nicht ausschließen können
aber und vielleicht reichen 100 jahre
politischer aschermittwoch auch
vielleicht sollte man langsam schluss
machen mit dieser tradition meine
herumgepöbelt wird im netz heute 24
stunden am tag dafür braucht man auch
kein bierzelt sonst noch konstruktive
vorschläge in meinen augen soll niemand
das abitur bekommen wenn er keine
nagelbrett schlagen kann
tja dann muss ich mainz wohl zurückgeben
gibt's das nicht schon in bremen
leistungskurs nageln ich meine schon
oder
ich meine schon da ist einfach bei denen
insgesamt diese aschermittwoch eine
etwas enttäuschende veranstaltung fand
ich und dann haben die lieben kollegen
von werde er noch einen ganz ganz
schlimm bock schoss der sven lorig
eigentlich guter mann hat sich da ein
versprecher geleistet der ja schlicht
nicht passieren darf hören sie mal ob
sie den fehler bemerken
und das hier ist der geheime motto war
der absolut geheime motto lag joseph
goebbels
ein baby
und das ist
der thüringische spd-chef
das darf nicht passieren meine damen und
herren ich bin sonst tolerant aber das
darf nicht passieren
der thüringische spd-chef heißt bernd
löcke wirklich leute es ist doch nicht
so schwer
und heute ist faktisch nicht der gaul
und vorsitzender der ard
der eigentliche vorsitzende der ard ist
bernd lucke sie sind in der verkündigung
ja schön dass jetzt wirklich keiner mehr
durchblickt
das wollten wir erreichen ja im grunde
ist der ganze politischer aschermittwoch
eine art hochamt des gepflegten das wird
man ja wohl noch sagen dürfen so gesehen
geradezu ein geschenk für die afd und
ihren brandenburger spitzenkandidaten
kallwitz ich möchte autobahn und
zigeunerschnitzel sagen können ohne
politische konnotation
ich möchte auch sagen können wer macht
kaffee möchte ich auch sagen dürfen
klar warum nicht oder kalbitz nazi aber
ohne politische konnotation einfach war
nicht da bock drauf habe
ja ja auch diese karnevals session
stellt uns allen wieder mal kein gutes
zeugnis aus in diesem sinne herzlich
willkommen zu
wulff stammt ist offiziell geisteskrank
produkten ähnlich beim lesen
ja heute so
die heute-show betriebs ihren arzt
doktor von heesen mit einer ja wirklich
schockierende diagnose
ich habe es immer gesagt eines tages
holen die uns ab ding dong ab in die
klapse erst diskutieren wir hier gefühlt
wochenlang über die aufregende frage
darf man witze über doppel haben machen
klar darf man ich erinnere hier nur an
das legendäre buch die besten
doppelnamen witze von gisela soll ich
vögele mit einem vorwort von dr manfred
büchsenschütz note steht alles drin
und jetzt hat irgendwo eine provinz
politikerin aus dem saarland
unterirdische pkk witze über
intersexuelle gemacht und als wir uns an
alle mal für zwei minuten abgelegt
hatten kam dies hier in dieser kinder
kita in hamburg ottensen sollen sich
kinder an karneval nicht mehr als
scheich oder indianer verkleiden um
stereotype zu überwinden und kulturen
nicht zu verletzen reaktionen vor der
kita heute ich finde das völlig gestört
weil will das würde ich bescheuert
so sieht es aus wenn hamburger vor wohl
auslassen und so bescheuert das ist wenn
eine einzelne kita in hamburg die eltern
bietet die indianer quasi noch mal
auszurotten diesmal als kostüm noch
bescheuerter ist die hysterisch jetzt
auch wer geehrt wird
ich wünsche mir ein deutschland in dem
kinder einfach kinder sein dürfen indem
sie draußen cowboy und indianer spielen
dürfen in dem kindergarten wahlweise
lichtwoche oder mit lego spielen dürfen
ich träume von einem deutschland in dem
fünfjährigen nicht mehr ins gefängnis
kommen wenn sie mit lego spielen in den
jungs als indianer verkleidet endlich
wieder päckchen verprügeln dürfen und
zwar draußen ja aber das war doch nur
eine kita und ich träume von einem
deutschland indem man einfach behaupten
darf es waren alle kitas und alle
schulen
ob jetzt indianer kostüme in schulen
erlaubt sind
liebe freunde das verboten worden ist
dass kinder ein scheiß kostüm tragen
dürfen
da bin ich froh dass ich mal ramsay
kehrt kostüm überhaupt noch trage konnte
am montag
was zum teufel ist ein ranziger kostüm
das weiß keiner aber ich will eins
tragen kommen
so sollen dafür hinten
[Applaus]
mal sagen sie dazu
mir ist das lg habe gehört in vielen
hamburger schulen müssen die jungs
morgens ihren pimmel abgeben können sie
sich nach der stelle wieder abholen ja
ich glaube ihre diagnose ist klar
geworden alle problem so sieht's aus
alle bekommt deswegen habe ich mir fürs
nächste jahr das ultimative kostüm
überlegt mit dem man hoffentlich alle
beleidigt ich nenne es mal transsexuelle
nazi indianer scheich nicht
die heute show am ende einer recht
spektakulären woche annegret kramp
karrenbauer hat aus versehen eine art
staatskrise ausgelöst mit ihrem witz
über toiletten für das dritte geschlecht
frage frage muss man als cdu vorsitzende
und kommende kanzlerin bei seinen
schlechten gags vorsichtiger sein als
andere menschen oder schließen sich
karneval und gute gags grundsätzlich aus
der akademische fragen und damit ein
klarer fall für dietmar wischmeyer
herrschaft in ruhe bitte herzlich
willkommen zum pro seminar humor trotz
karneval der deutsche karneval völlig
zurecht und tesco weltkulturerbe selbst
seit jahrzehnten auf die bewährte humor
formel nach inca plus kröten gleich
witzig im gegensatz zur elitären
hochkultur ein biotop des bodenständigen
eines der letzten reservate in denen der
mann noch kein kastrierter weg sein muss
auch das dort gepflegte liegt gut ist
oft viel tiefgründiger als der laie
denkt diese romantische ballade zum
beispiel hat die ganze miete bewegung im
grunde schon vorweggenommen
[Musik]
wunderbar diese lebensbejahende zeile
entstammt übrigens dem historischen
faschings lied tippen garbsen quark
alles für eine mark das wahre elend
begann aber erst als unsere politiker
den karneval entdeckten um sich als
gemeine volk rand zu wanzen sowie ad
annegret das genau weiß was die
einfachen leute hören wollen dort gut
statt böse wer war denn von euch vor
kurzem mal in berlin
da seht ihr doch die latte macchiato
fraktion die da die feinen leute aus der
hauptstadt trinken kaffee mit
aufgeschäumter milch
dabei gibt es die latte dann jeder tanke
diese wünsche es farbiger satz
flüssigkeit aber unter saarländischen
provinz matronen geht sie immer noch als
ausweis urban schlendrian diese koffein
süchtigen berliner tage liebe bauen
nämlich den ganzen tag über flüssige
scheiß häuser das ist für die männer die
noch nicht wissen ob sie noch stehen
dürfen beim pinkeln oder schon sitzen
lassen
wow der traut sich was eins der
schönsten klischees der deutschen humor
hölle der unter dem pantoffel des weibes
stehende mann zu blöd um selber zu
entscheiden in welcher kabine neben die
schüssel wissen soll
mein vorschlag karneval den
karnevalisten politiker raus dann kann
die fünfte jahreszeit vielleicht
irgendwann wieder so unschuldig werden
wie früher
wie gesagt es sind doch max it webseiten
mein arzt hat mir verboten mich
weiterhin so aufzuregen
deswegen wollte ich euch allen einfach
nur einen schönen taz menschen überall
lassen die ihre dreggsagg michl liegen
und ihr lasst jetzt slx ein beschissenes
autobahn
[Musik]